la carte orange et sur les notions à ppr
je ne captera
pour ce qui est des zones d'ombré je
suis très conscient de ce problème mais
il faut bien voir que légalement nous
pouvons intervenir que de la région
transports parisiens qui est définie par
une autre en 1959 était ménages y a
plusieurs fois qu'il s'en prend
d'ailleurs encore à l'avenir n'est que
actuellement cette réforme car il s'agit
bien d'une réforme touche 9 millions
d'habitants de région parisienne sur le
disque comprend au total c'est à dire
que les hommes sont peu nombreuses et
qu'on peut espérer qu'à l'avenir on
rêvera les résorber
de ma carte orange je sors mon ticket
mon ticket porte le nom du mois pour
lequel les valeurs et à la fin de ce mot
là il n'est plus valable d'ailleurs le
codage des postes contre on le change ce
qui fait qu'il est impossible d'utiliser
à partir la fin du mois il faut donc à
partir du 20 de chaque mois les usagers
se conclure le coupon dimensionnelle
et je comprends mais je n'ai même pas
composté donc je commenterai pas
d'accord c'est le rôle à composter c'est
indiqué sur une toile mettre dans la
file santé de transport permanent et si
vous le composter vous le rendre
inutilisable
donc je veux commenter l'accord une fête
qui me montre à la carte parfait c'est
essentiellement un système de
simplification des dents tarification
transports en commun et c'est aussi une
simplification qui rend vers une
diminution de crue du coût des
transports en commun dans la région
parisienne je pense que ce sont là les
deux caractéristiques essentielles
réformes car il ajouté
réforme qui va dans le sens de cette
promotion transports en commun de la
région parisienne que le gouvernement
veut réaliser